hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm cat Das
and we're gonna watch the trailer for
this movie called
something about Dracula that everyone is
saying looks really cool you totally
could be a vampire dude I know you like
how that look I do why don't you become
a vampire
well I hung out with you at the beach
day during the day
BAM Mitch in the last two videos I heard
a bikini there's awesome Shh I'm telling
them something important okay sar in a
bikini it's as good as you imagined it
to be and like I said in the previous
photo I'm looking for some new portraits
of Karen oh no that's okay thank you so
much we're good Dracula untold now it's
Dracula movie apparently and a lot of
people are saying how cool this film
actually looks I love Dracula movies I'm
not gonna lie anything with vampires oh
I was highlight you know wasn't really
what I was hoping for like it was a
little bit you know that wasn't like my
favorite but I love a good vampire film
I love a good vampire film too we made
eye contact today and that was the most
intimacy I've had with a girl in so many
months I'm sorry to hear that
so you don't make eye contact that often
cuz you must run into women like all the
time right yeah that's rare I'm very shy
my head just goes down that's why I wear
this hat now the universal and legendary
meet
my father was a great
[Music]
how cool he's going out for a little bit
there
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
you are lighted because you can fight
because of what I take just a view
okay that looks pretty [ __ ] sweet I
love that that is like they did uh
they're doing a different type of take
on Dracula origin one and they're really
committed to this different version you
know yeah it looks pretty cool it
doesn't look like I Frankenstein the
first movie we did together it doesn't
that i frankenstein world was like hey
we want to do a different type of
frankenstein version but it's gonna sigh
like this one looks like they really
haven't clear about what they were going
for here she's got a motivation you know
protecting his family and its people
mm-hmm and I like how he became the
vampire I think that was not Sprott to
I'm sure someone will look like him
definitely like oh yeah I don't know the
exact learn just trying to figure out
who everyone is
I thought not for right I thought
Dracula was like considered a ripoff of
Maserati I mean Dracula was I mean that
book was written so long ago yeah before
that movie came out and I saw to you you
know sometimes soft-spoken you are some
time ago things could have changed like
you get into like this really sweet
voice where you seem like you really
cared communicating to me no yeah the
movie does look sweet and you're right
just have to kind of have like that Game
of Thrones vibe about like they're
crossing sci-fi/fantasy
along with like a pickle oh yeah
historical war [ __ ] if I can mentally
tie something of the game of thrones
I'll go watch it no yeah totally
hi I know cuz hi I've watched every
episode so I still can't believe you
haven't oh no I just I've seen all my
stairs their swords and Dragons and sex
and blood and just so much well one time
this guy got his head cut off which gay
camera member his name right now by
is very violent when it happened and
nonviolent beheadings yeah
and there are two main characters having
sex at one point yeah
Game of Thrones according to Ryan right
well guys if you're new to the channel
you can do this that's all I got today
hey you can subscribe good for you
no one gives a [ __ ] about the trailer so
about the shuttle about the shoutouts
Leo Pelle you're so [ __ ] funny you
make my day can you please give me a
shout-out
well we oh of course you can buddy
gosh your hats off to you I'm gonna show
you my hat hair right now my sweaty had
her that's wet whenever I'm around Kat
Ken and I bought it in and out
I bye Nana was her about like two hours
ago and I still have not touched it
are you yeah she did this curl can down
like anything he would know he's just
Leo I'm telling you when you imagine her
tonight you know right before you're
about to go to bed mommy kisses you
goodnight you jack off into a sock Oh
Leo will be thinking to you and remember
she can handle anything in that mouth of
hers he assumes since you didn't know no
this is factual information done a lot
of research on this okay jiggly jelly
it's what I call my balls
alright yeah baby groovy my nice bro
more subs to come shout-out to jelly woo
jiggly jelly yeah okay I guess it's lots
of work like jiggly jelly yeah baby
groovy jiggly jelly Batman anyway I'm
gonna start saying that now jiggly
jiggly jelly
Amy jiggly jelly I'm gonna start calling
a lot of things that so yeah it could
work at any situation there's a fire you
could be like jiggly jelly there's a
fire yeah
yeah jiggle jellyfish
why didn't you turn that goddamn jiggly
jelly phone off cat iron wiser he said
shout out please
well iron wiser that's Iron Man's
mentally challenged brother Iron Man
take care of your anything you just
can't joke around about but you end up
doing them anyway well I was er yeah
that is my shout out to you and cat will
now show you her cleavage
no can't sorry iron wazzle wants a video
you know how to just infuriate me
sometimes you know just liked just a
little bit of cleavage today cat come on
what's the big deal
I saw your bikini today great body we
all went to the beach great body
well thank you I appreciate that how can
I mention your tattoo yeah she doesn't
have a tattoo okay I have a tattoo I got
when I was like it's that this sexy part
right by your oh my head no tight on the
hips like right below the no it's like
right here on the side and I got it a
long time ago when I was a kid yes
[ __ ] Holocaust
I need you to laser enough but yeah no I
just wanted to touch I forget I have it
till I go to the beach like oh there it
is still there touch my arm was hurt
enough you know what I mean all of your
guys's names can be [ __ ] dick names